1997 every conversation i had in short
hills millburn springfield new jersey
gary
who on earth is going to buy wine on the
world wide web gary's answer everyone
2006 why would anybody care about
twitter when i was explaining twitter
because i was an early investor in 2006
everybody thought it was the stupidest
thing that i ever said they're like who
cares if somebody's having a pizza gary
who cares if i'm walking the dog my
answer
everyone
i'm a purebred entrepreneur for real for
real for real like documenting
[Music]
hey
if i didn't have enough after this
weekend
i think i have three talks today
right
ridiculous
there are three talks today in vegas uh
there's a licensing show there's a video
call video conference building brand of
video in the end and then a toys r us
right
nice conversation a little daily be
action here in vegas
looking forward to it
[Music]
what's up boys
it was really good have you come down
with it
i'm just starting to which is good
incredible
i mean considering the first year just
thinking about
four to seven core things i'm gonna do
different next year that i'm just gonna
take it to the moon
really pumped we did the toy museum
the
the brand building for that
the reaction of everyone because we were
obviously lovely incognito yeah it was
so fun and they're like what are you
guys doing are they going we're just
going to
play some toys and they're like oh my
god
it's great i love them
please don't have your opinion on nfts
based on one friend's opinion on it
please spend the 25 hours to understand
what the blockchain actually is what it
actually means how it's actually going
to impact because it's going to impact
everybody on earth and this is why the
hundred hours of education i put in to
understanding the blockchain and
consumer behavior and operational
functionality you got to put all these
pieces together and then it starts
getting interesting
saying no with no education
is as bad of a move as you can do
garyvee thank you so much for being here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you thank you are we on time uh
we're almost we gotta hustle
am i on stage in six minutes yes you are
so let's move forward
thank you it's really nice to be here i
think business has a bad name i think
we've missed branded business
the brand of business is broken
i think a lot of people
have very honorable very kind business
skills and the world thinks business is
rough and sharp elbows and
nice
like
even like it just made me like jump up a
little bit this concept that the world
has been pushing on us that nice guys
finish last is a travesty
it's a travesty that people believe that
it makes people behave in ways that they
don't have in their soul
and it's broken and i think we have to
have a new conversation
i think hard skills are commoditized
machine learning ai many other things
that's where the commodity is it's the
people that know how to lead too many
people lead out of fear it's not healthy
it doesn't work in the end and i just
think we need to have a more thoughtful
conversation i'm not talking about let's
do foofy foofy entitlement everyone's
now thinking about like what about these
[ __ ] gen zeirs they don't want to do
[ __ ] i'm not talking about that
i'm not talking about like we have to do
stuff of course i'm talking about
people using negativity
and and fear as drivers yeah
nobody wants to be scared of their boss
so many people so many people are
struggling when i'm pushing this out
because they're worried about
entitlement and i understand that
it is a fine balance
but
we just need to have a different combo
because you get way more out of honey
than vinegar it is documented proof but
most of all the thing that bothers me
the most is i watch nice people
navigate their careers and try to
develop less nice skills because they
believe subconsciously and consciously
that it gets them further and that has
to be eradicated
thank you
thank you everybody have a great time
why are we doing that i always do this
working on our passions never quitting
your day dreams don't got a bands or a
house or a jet or the money that the
internet claims we should get what i got
is a drive and a soul and a sense that
can spark everybody to believe in they
sell hey you inspire me every day good
luck
pleasure i'm an old dude right but old
dude it's me something all the time i'm
humble
two years ago i was diagnosed with ms
i'm sorry and i thought that stood for
money syndrome
but it doesn't i had to look that up
thank you brother thank you i appreciate
it
thank you
every day is a gift
[Music]
today we have the people's entrepreneur
mr motivational himself uh the letter of
e in the alphabet essentially belongs to
him for sure vaynerchuk welcome to the
show thank you men i
have no attachment to any of my
successor accolades my parents had sex
at the right second
my mom raised me my circumstance built
me grew up with a whole lot of little
which made me super hungry my mom
instilled heavy levels of kindness be
nice to people in me so when i say
things like that i don't think i'm
special i think my parents and my
circumstance was special it's why i can
deal with accolades you know and hate
like the reason i am me is because when
i see i post something and the comments
are very consistent 86
go go go go go go goat
14
scam piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] you uh
my life is literally this like when
people like you're the greatest of all
time i'm like
okay whatever when people are like
you're a piece of [ __ ] i'm like you
don't know me yeah yeah and that like
and that's it where do you think
parenting
is going to shift really what do you
think the secret's going to be for this
next generation we're just in our kids
[ __ ] too much
like you know i really think from my
perspective one man's point of view and
by the way on the record it's really
important
the audacity to tell somebody how to
parent their kids is ludicrous i would
never have interest right
these are just social observations based
on getting 10 000 dm's a week and seeing
what kids which is good yeah these are
just i think that we need to get out of
our kids [ __ ] sure kids are also
struggling because when i was a kid and
definitely everybody older than me
you kind of had to figure out your [ __ ]
for you your mommy and daddy didn't
fight it out yeah yeah now we're in our
kids [ __ ] we're fighting the teachers
we're fighting the other kid and like it
makes people incapable of working [ __ ]
out
and so i the thing that i don't see
happening yet is i still see parents
really be interested in like fighting it
out for their kids i think kids need to
fight out their own fights they do uh
gary honestly i wish i could talk to you
for six hours thank you so much for
coming on the show we appreciate that as
always guy thank you for tuning in as
always we'll see you next week
like tiki barbara now my back and coming
larger i'm riding in the farm but i used
to ride the martyr just got off the
phone with gary b he taught me to go
harder feel pretty on fire there
focused
clear vision
a lot of fun good energy i like i like
podcasts that three before
guys or gals like
something with the group setting does
even more for me
um
i think what stood out what's it up
without
[Music]
parenting
i like the parenting stuff a lot the
parenting stuff's tough because i think
it's an asinine to tell somebody how to
pair it which is why i never would do it
like one-on-one but in the macro i like
talking about the themes i'm in such a
luxurious place where i'm getting
between tik tok and instagram just on a
godly amount of information from 11 to
25
and so there's some insights there that
i'm trying to like and you know just you
always hope when you do something like
that when i when i go there i'm like if
one parent
hears this and it makes sense it can
change a kid's life and i got a lot of
that at vcon you changing the way up
here changing my parents going better
but it's really nice and that becomes
like an ode to my mom you know like
i feel like that's the way i can pay
back like my mom that's the way i could
put her on a pedestal
one thing you know i talked about in the
podcast one thing that i think is so
fascinating is i wonder if i can get
others to
see themselves the way i do which is
just like a
like kind of like an empty
pipe
i'm just an empty pipe it's like you
give me accolades my mom you [ __ ] on me
you just don't know me it's all empty
it's just like
there's something about when you don't
like
when you don't overvalue yourself when
you don't have ego
and it's confidence and humility
like if you think of that as a triangle
i think of ego confidence and humility
as a triangle and like the game is like
if you can just go focus just on hey you
have self-esteem like i'm a good person
i'm doing the best i can
doing the best i can
and
and humility like if it's going well
being like yeah okay there's been
there's eight billion people on earth
i'm sure there's billions that are doing
it better than me you know better
looking me nicer me smarter me if you
can play on that you win if you go to
ego which is just insecurity it's all
over you think you're [ __ ]
so then you make pretend that you're
good
and you [ __ ] on everyone you think
you're [ __ ] so it's lack of
self-confidence
so then you spend all your time [ __ ]
on everybody else and fake pretending
that you're good
right
posturing yeah
all to protect that you're weak so we've
got to figure out how to get everybody
to love themselves
which is why we have to change success
from money
because not everybody has skills to make
money
but we can teach everybody to have
skills in being content and happy for
what they have gratitude
[Music]
this is the green room yeah blueberries
i love blueberries
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
what's good vegas
[Applause]
very humbled thank you people walking
around here thinking there's somebody
because they got 230 000 followers on
tick tock
so
humble the [ __ ] up
[ __ ] will get better but a lot of you
say no to [ __ ]
because your humility's not in check i
still say yes to [ __ ] that a lot of you
pass on
because i out humble you
all right that was some like you know i
just hope everybody knows
no i just realized it's important i just
really i want everybody know that's not
me razzing that's me loving you
i see a lot of people saying no to [ __ ]
as if there's somebody
you want to really win decide you're
nobody everything gets real interesting
real fast after that
garyvee
[Applause]
[Music]
that's crazy
[Music]
wow
i'm happy to pay for it but like i
really want this like i really want this
thank you my dude this is fire
it's fire thank you so much
i don't need any more
feel accomplished got some good rest
last night we'll get good tomorrow get
back on the east coast schedule it's
been a long
long week
between getting to minnesota and doing
v-con and now this incense intense day
in vegas but a lot of fun fun to be with
andrew and uh
you know new team action vibes feel
fresh good insights
[Music]
overseas
[Music]